[Music]
let us pick up from where we left off
agricultural practices right we decided
to learn the various processes used for
the activity of Agriculture what do you
think is the most important requirement
for agriculture soil that's right but do
you know that soil needs to be prepared
for crop production yes soil is usually
found solidified into hard chunks of
soil mass this soil needs to be softened
and loosened
why does soil need to be loosened up
before cultivation the answer is simple
loose soil will allow more air to pass
to the roots of the plants this will in
turn aid the growth of the plant leading
to good crop production do you know any
natural agents that help this process we
usually refer to them as friends of the
farmers yes the answer is earthworms
they help loosen the soil and also its
soil aeration do you know another
advantage of loosening of the soil it
also helps the soil to retain water it
then leads to the growth of favourable
microbes that help to produce humors in
the soil
what exactly is houmous as we know all
living things die their remains are
decomposed and nutrients are returned
back to the soil the microbes help in
this process of decomposition this
decomposed matter is rich in nutrients
and is known as humors it is what plants
depend on for nutrition do you also know
that loosening up of soil has yet
another benefit plants mostly take
nutrients from the top layers of soil
and they are unable to go deeper into
the soil loosening up the soil helps to
turn the lower soil and makes it
accessible to the plant does the
nutrients in the lower layers are
brought up to the upper layers of the
soil so what does this process of
loosening and turning of soil cold we
call it tilling or plowing in
agriculture how is tilling and plowing
done by man have you heard the name of
an equipment called plough yes how
sure you have it helps to lose in the
soil but what if the soil is hard would
it be easy to plow no it won't be
hence the soil may have to be watered
before plowing even after plowing huge
chunks of soil could be left behind
these chunks need to be broken down into
smaller fragments soil also needs to be
leveled so that the land is even and
sowing of seeds can take place on this
land what if the soil has not regained
its fertility do we add some manure to
it yes of course
when your tube can be added to make the
soil fertile now let us look closely at
the equipment's that aid the process of
tilling or plowing the land there are
mainly three types of equipments used in
the first stage of Agriculture a plow
hoe and a cultivator are the three major
ones do you know how any of these work
or how they look don't worry in case you
haven't we will study each of them in
detail in our next video
[Music]